do they ever come back to life in that
moment that's a very important point
though because that could happen you're
quite right to think about it that is
possible theoretically uh again because
just because they call you legally dead
doesn't mean everything is stopped the
point when your body gives out i don't
want to call die because that's not not
really what's happening we'll get into
that as to are you actually dead or not
because i don't think you are but your
body gives out your heart fails whatever
something critical goes uh in an ideal
situation we're right there at the
bedside and we can begin within seconds
of legal death being pronounced and do
you have to wait for someone to be there
like does a coroner have to show up or
like at least a you know kind of smart
policeman or something to say hey yeah
you guys are good to get in there
they're dead generally no um
we hate those cases when you have
coroners or or medical examiners
in most cases you just wait for a doctor
to declare legal death uh i think in
some cases it can be a special kind of
nurse but legal death has to be declared
and it's very important to understand
how that's different from other things
but you know coroners or medical
examiners that's a disaster when they
get involved because you have to wait
for them to arrive which could be an
hour or more and they're slow so i mean
they're dawdling they take their time
yeah and they have like gods they have
complete power it doesn't matter if you
have a religious objection they can do
it anyway and they often will and that
can be a disaster that can be as bad as
taking the brain out of your head
slicing into pieces uh and then shoving
it back into your stomach which is as
nasty as it sounds
it doesn't have to be that bad uh we've
had a lot of success in i mean they will
autopsy if you're driving a car you have
an accident they're going to autopsy you
okay slow it down a little bit for me so
i can be yeah i am yeah i'm i'm so
you're okay so you have
so the corners and those kind of guys
can be a hindrance it can be a hold up
so you want to be already involved with
the presumed patient that you're going
to freeze you want to be already
involved with them and hopefully there's
like a medical per there you know at the
end of their life with a doctor or
they're in hospice hospital or hospice
someone can
someone can pronounce pronounce them
legally dead and then you guys can be
there right and right then you guys
start
what do you do like right like
do you give them a couple minutes to
kind of like be like with the lord or
whatever do you just get right in there
we get right in there wow ideally i mean
we're not always able to get there
before little death is pronounced we
want to get there as quick as we can
it's not essential but it's certainly
better so ideally we're at the bedside
the doctor says i declare you legally
dead okay and let's just go into that
for a second before we go into the
procedure because it's really important
when they say i declare you legally that
what does that mean exactly does it mean
your whole body's dead all your cells
are dead no
it can't mean that because people donate
their organs all the time right so all
these things are still alive just
something critical has failed and in
fact many times when you're declared
legally dead they could actually
resuscitate you that's why people have
dnr do not resuscitate orders because
they're saying
please don't resuscitate me because i'm
just gonna be miserable and horrible for
a couple of hours and then fail again
right wow so it's very important that
legal death is not the same as
everything suddenly dying that doesn't
happen i see so it just has to be
legally dead and then there's still a
lot of life going on inside people yeah
so that's when you guys get in that's
when we get in there and what we do uh
uh try and keep it relatively simple
because it's a complex procedure
basically what we'll take the patient
move them from the hospital bed or the
hospice bed into an ice bath we'll cover
them with ice add some water we have a
device that circulates that icy slurry
around them to accelerate the cooling
process and what temperature is that
that you put them in well it's just yeah
it's just ice water so we don't want to
go below freezing at this point because
that would damage the cells we haven't
protected them yet so um we're going to
put icy water this starts circulating
we'll put on a mechanical cpr device to
start pumping on their chest and a
respirator to take over breathing so
we're actually restarting circulation
and respiration
you might say why are you doing that
this person's dead well as you said
they're not really dead in any
interesting sense and we have to
preserve the viability of the tissues
just like someone donating an organ or a
kidney we want to keep it viable there
you have to keep it vital for several
hours while you send it across country
yeah when i was young my sister got a
liver transplant when i was younger when
we were kids
and she um
yeah i guess they had to move the organ
pretty quick and then get it
they don't last that long
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one